friday follies for that we turn to fox
news contributor raymond arroyo
raymond biden signed some more executive
orders and actions this week that can't
be possible
now far 40 so far laura look
though his introduction to some of them
uh you you're not quite sure if biden
fully understands that he's president
and what his administration is actually
doing
like the previous administration will
start to properly manage
unlike it we're going to start to
properly manage lands and
waterways the second order i'm going to
be signing
also changes what the president has done
president of the president what former
president has done
and that a memorandum reversed the
my predecessor's attack on women's
health
according to health access and
as we continue to battle cover 19.
no wonder he's choking on that laura let
me translate what he's saying there
biden actually signed an action to
overturn
the trump policy which banned federal
funding of abortions abroad
that's why he's coughing and and look uh
it has
nothing to do with health care but the
taxpayer picking up
uh abortions abroad that's what this is
really about
even though 77 percent of americans in a
new marist poll
including democrats oppose that policy
but remember as nancy pelosi has said
they're all devout catholics raymond now
jen sake's spin on this was
quite compelling in terms of
executive actions that includes
overturning some of the detrimental
harmful and at times immoral policies uh
and
actions of the prior administration so
the the trump policies
uh stopping the funding of abortions
abroad that was immoral
laura i mean it's a wonder there wasn't
a flash of lightning in the press room
the executive action she's talking about
is truly about
killing children abroad and you know for
an administration that's been so focused
worried about separating foreign
children from their parents
we are now going to pay as taxpayers to
permanently
separate foreign children from their
parents i hardly see this as an advance
in the agenda
of people yeah raymond the timing of
this is
tell me about the timing why they do it
now well it comes on the eve
of the pro-life march the march for life
that's when this happened but
very hard for a catholic like biden to
talk about dignity
respect for the human person and then
enact these policies in addition to this
there was a planned parenthood bailout
he also signed really bad policy yeah so
planned parenthood gets big money
they get big money small businesses that
actually produce jobs and
help life are struggling and we're
paying for
abortions abroad and they're the more
you shouldn't worry about any of that
laura close your eyes to how the money's
being spent or the lousy policies
the media is serving up marquee malarkey
like this
bunch of milwaukee
there is now an official dictionary
approved term for the role the official
role filled by doug emhoff vice
president
kamala harris's husband here it is
second gentleman
emhoff the new second gentleman is just
like jill biden
continuing to work in his own capacity
so many americans are
in families that look like um
very different than what maybe was leave
it to beaver
in the 1950s it's really cathartic
and refreshing to see that reflected in
the highest office
or at least the second highest office in
the land laura it's amazing how these
reports cover kamal harris and her
family
as if she were already president well
they they cover
the diversity aspect of things what her
pant suit looks like
her daughter you know gets a a modeling
contract that's great
good for them right but there's no
coverage of what's coming
tax hikes our allies embracing china
uh but the ap just dropped this this
story raymond uh
hold your horses or dogs biden's two
dogs
settle in at the white house oh my gosh
they're still covering their dogs why is
this news
40 executive actions and orders do these
reporters have something else they might
cover
anything i'm bracing myself for the
first kitten spreads
coming any day now no raymond i i i
think we really have to cover this in
depth i mean if we're going to do dog
coverage
i want to know their rabies vaccination
i want to know when they're getting
dewormed okay when are they getting
their nails clipped
you know what isn't it enough that we
have to watch kamala and jill getting
their shots and
and dewormed we don't need to see the
dogs i'm sorry i draw the line here
raymond disney your favorite has
announced that
it's altering their classic jungle
cruise attraction
to omit what the la times described
as racist stereotypes what is that about
well this is like splash mountain laura
splash mountain 2.0
disney says it will remove negative
depictions of some cultures in that
jungle cruise attraction
essentially the natives and the
headhunter who appears
as a gag at the end of the ride they're
out but the new addition seemed to my
eye more insensitive than what's there
now
they will replace the native people with
chimps attacking a sunken
boat so is disney saying there were no
violent tribes in africa
and my biggest problem here is this is
an attraction that was actually
overseen and created by walt disney
himself in 1955
here's how he explained it on tv it all
started
with an idea that sprang from our true
life adventure film
jungle resident guaranteed to furnish
chills even in the warmest weather
is this cannibal chieftain raymond
they should have had the founding
fathers attack the boats okay
if it was thomas jefferson and j that
would have been okay
well this is my problem if you have if
there's a sensitivity to something in
these attractions now
interpret them put them in context but
don't rip them apart
walt disney is a 20th century creative
vision
that has captured the world like norman
rockwell or louis armstrong you leave it
as it is
let people interpret it through time all
right raymond thanks so much